[Music]
the original dates for adele's las vegas
residency have passed and the singer
hasn't yet taken to the stage on the
strip but her run at caesar's palace was
postponed as you probably heard and
after things were silent for several
months there are now reports she could
be changing venues madison kimbrough
live on the strip tonight with the
details
[Music]
so when adele postponed her residency at
caesars it left a lot of ticket holders
wondering if they would ever get to see
adele perform live here in vegas but
according to tmz adele is finalizing a
deal to move her residency right here to
planet hollywood
we had looked at getting tickets
christmas time and we were kind of
grateful we didn't when it was all
canceled weekends with adele at the
coliseum at caesar's palace was supposed
to debut this past january in vegas but
due to covid and creative differences
the musician announced that her
residency dates would be rescheduled but
recently reports from tmz have surfaced
that her residency is returning but this
time at zappos theater at planet
hollywood the coliseum and zappos are
both within the caesars entertainment
family but even so people on the strip
have mixed reaction if her residency was
to move it would be
sad to see it not here i think it would
be missing out on the experience of that
venue part of it is the intimacy of the
caesars doesn't matter where you're
sitting you feel like you're right
beside them when it does come back
whether it be at zappos or the caesars
it's just as amazing as we all expected
it to be as for those still wondering
what to do with their tickets places
like ticketmaster telling patrons that
their tickets are still valid as they'll
be sent an email reminder when dates are
rescheduled but also giving the option
to those who want their money back the
ability to request a full refund
[Music]
we reached out to caesars for
confirmation about the possible move but
have yet to hear back reporting live on
the strip madison kimbrough live local
now